the government created the following
stem and leaf plot showing the number of
turtles at each major zoo in the country
how many zoo zoos have fewer than 46
turtles so what the stump stem and leaf
prop plot does is it gives us the first
digit in each number and essentially you
could say call this the tens place and
then it gives us the ones place so there
was only one zoo that had four turtles
so you could view this as zero
zero four or four turtles then there's
well you see so
everything here the tens place is a one
so this this number right over here is
really an 11. this is a 14
this right over here would be a 16
that's a 16
and so forth and so on this would be 17
18. all of this this is 23 this is 23
this is 26 because we have our tens
place right over here this is the first
digit so let's go answer the question
how many zoos had fewer than 46 turtles
so
there are no zoos that had 40 anything
turtles and so all of these zoos here so
all of these had 30-something turtles
these had 20-something turtles these
have in the teens this have single
digits so it's literally as many zoos as
we have listed here so one two three
four five six seven eight
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17. 17 zoos have
fewer than 46 turtles
let's do another one
the buyer for a chain of supermarkets
created the following stem and leaf plot
showing the number of coconuts at each
of the stores
what was the smallest number of coconuts
at any one grocery store so the buyer
for chain of supermarkets created the
following stem of leaf plots showing the
number of coconuts at each of the stores
so at any one grocery store the smallest
number well that's this one right over
here remember it's not two
we have our tens places right over here
it's a one so this right over here
represents 12 coconuts at that store
so we'll put 12 right over here let's
try out another one
a statistician for a chain of department
stores created the following stem and
leaf plot showing the number of watches
at each of the stores
how many department stores have exactly
seven watches
well that's only this one right over
here zero seven watches this one right
this
this and that one are not seven this is
representing 17 because it's in the row
with one at the beginning this right
over here represents
27. so because it's in the row with the
two at the beginning so there's only one
store that has exactly seven watches
let's do one more this is kind of fun
a zookeeper created the following stem
and leaf plot showing the number of
tigers at each major zoo in the country
how many zoos have more than 24 tigers
so we can ignore the zeros and the teens
and we get in the 20s this is 25 so that
meets the criteria and then you go to 28
29 so all of these all of these in the
30s and all of these right over here
this three zero this doesn't mean zero
tigers this is 30 tigers this is 40
tigers so we count one two three four
five six seven eight nine nine zoos have
more than 24 tigers
nine zoos and we're done